and how did you get to then to Hollywood
to be a writer for television well that
was you know I never actually wanted I
like watching television but I never
wanted to be a writer for television it
was not part of my dreams I just wanted
to write books and it all had to do with
commercial vagaries of the market and
actually with you know there's a lot of
truth to the old saying it's not what
you know it's who you know especially in
in Hollywood where contacts are a huge
part of it I was a science fiction
writer and a in my early career and I
published a number of short stories I
was nominated for awards I won some
awards six or seven years into it I
wrote my first novel which was pretty
successful then I wrote a second novel
in collaboration and that was even more
successful and my third novel was was a
vampire novel that that kind of broke
out of the strict John were things and
that was yet even more successful when I
was getting higher and higher advances
for all of these and then I wrote my
fourth novel which was a book called the
Armageddon rag which was a rock and roll
mystery dark fantasy kind of hybrid
novel that my editors said well this is
gonna be it this is your big
breakthrough the book that says we're
gonna make this book a best-seller and
they paid me a six-figure advance for it
and came up with this big advertising
campaign to make it a best-seller and it
was great I was looking forward to my
you know incipient career as a as a
famous best-selling writer the only
problem was the book failed to best sell
in fact it failed to sell at all it
became like my worst selling book that I
had ever written and suddenly my career
as a novelist was over because after
that I couldn't get arrested you know
I'd been like a hot rising writer for
for a number of years and you know
publishing is not unlike Hollywood in
that it's it's not a profession and I
know you guys are film students and and
into this thing it's it's not a
profession built for security if
security is important
you don't go into this profession
because you know you can be the hottest
thing in town on Tuesday and on
Wednesday nobody's gonna return your
calls one of those dear friends that you
think you had that you've been having
lunch and that certainly happened to me
suddenly I couldn't sell another novel
at any price I thought okay well the
armor getting rare failed I'll have to
come down in my price I won't get a
six-figure advance again but I'll get
like a high five figure advance like I
did for favorite room no you know I'll
get like a loaf I figure advance no you
know by the end I was willing even
listen to offers for a four figure
advance but nobody was offering anything
as the the book had sold so dismal I got
great reviews
but oddly enough this self same book too
destroyed my my career in in publishing
also opened the door to Hollywood for me
because my my film agent showed it to
another client of his a guy named Phil
de Guerre and Phil was a experienced
television writer he'd been on a number
of shows as a staff writer and producer
and he'd recently gone on to to do his
own show and he had a hit show called
Simon and Simon that he had invented and
he was coming up when another show
called whiz kids one of the first shows
about computer hackers and but what what
our agent we had the same agent Marvin
knew was that Phil was also a dead rock
and roll guy and he was a Deadhead and
he'd love to go to a Grateful Dead
concerts he knew all the dead he had
backstage passes and things like that
and he knew the rag would appeal to him
so I showed him arm again rag and indeed
Phil did one appeal he wanted to get
into feature films so he optioned
Armageddon rag for a feature film and he
was gonna write it himself right to
screenplay himself he was gonna direct
it himself and the first thing he did
was fly me out to Los Angeles to talk to
me about it now I'd sold other options
before I'd you know you if you have a
lot of books and short stories and they
get any kind of attention in those days
especially you'd find some one option
them in Hollywood
worldís little changed a lot we're
talking now the the early 80s so it
doesn't work quite the same way anymore
but in those days these cheap options
were we're all over and I would have
four or five or six of my short stories
and things under option simultaneously
but normally they just the option that
they send you a check you know you never
actually met any of these people or
talked to them they didn't care you were
just the author of the original material
they didn't necessarily want to involved
you in the process but Phil did and so
he flew me out and we had some meetings
and we discussed how he would do the
Armageddon rag and you know who - tricky
points about the novels and so forth and
I got the visit TV sets and watch I'm
filming Simon and Simon and watched him
filming the whiz kids which sort of was
his Armageddon rag that sank without a
trace after a short time but he was
still hot enough so that I made that
contact with Phil and we remained
friendly so like a year two passes and
suddenly CBS has said to Phil well we
want to get another show from the
assignment Simon is doing real well what
else do you got and Phil says I want to
bring back Twilight Zone I always love
Twilight Zone okay well sure we own
Twilight Zone you can bring it back so
Phil ramped up to to do Twilight Zone
and he turned to a lot of science
fiction and fantasy prose writers and
called me up and said hey ever think of
doing a writing for television doing a
Twilight Zone episode and you know since
I was rapidly well in fact I had run out
of money and was wondering how I was
gonna pay my mortgage and couldn't sell
another book because of a failure
American Rag I was eager to try this new
thing and I said sure I'll do some
Twilight zones and I I wrote a script
for him and led to another script and
etc etc next thing I knew I wanted
myself as a staff writer moving to LA
for six weeks or so to work on the under
Twilight Zone staff and after that came
Beauty and the Beast and it was two
seasons of Twilight Zone and a brief
flirtation what Max Headroom was in
there briefly and then
than beauty and a beast for three years
and in five years in you know
development which sometimes known as
development hell so all told I spent
about ten years primarily working in in
Hollywood you know I enjoyed my my 10
years up in Hollywood I learned a lot
from it it was very valuable to me in a
number of ways not only financially
where it certainly was helpful to me
after the situation I'd find myself in
after Armageddon wreck but also you know
as a writer I learned things I but there
were also frustrations there's just no
doubt that while working in television
and film requires a certain temperament
and skills that prose writers book
writers don't necessarily need or or
often have and I found that on both
Twilight Zone a beauty and a beast and
and even later in development the the
thing that really I think drove me back
to prose well there were a number of
things but what one of them was the
constant the constant arguments with
with other people the the politics the
the fighting of it it's it's you know
when I sit down to write ice and fire I
can just do the work and ultimately I am
the judge yes I have editors and my
editors make suggestions to me they say
well we don't think this thing is
working and I give where their words
consideration and I change things if I
think they should be changed but in
television and film of course here
you've got all these people the studio
and the network and the standards and
practices department and and the actors
and the directors and the producers and
sometimes it's hard enough to do the
good work and then you do the good work
and then there's other people want to
mess around with it or they have their
own idea and all that and so you have to
have a temperament no need to do too
good work but to fight for your work and
I don't necessarily enjoy fighting after
after I mean I did it and I defended my
work as best I can and I won someone I
lost some but after a while some of it
just just wore me out you know that if
you're no beauty and a beast the show we
always wanted to do show us like this
character base shows I think from the
very beginning the network wanted us to
be the Hulk they were they wanted a much
more formulaic show that was much more
action-oriented where Catherine would
get in trouble every week and Vincent
would be stout and come to a rescue and
and there are more shows that fit that
criteria I think you'll see in the first
season where you know and and they even
said well can we you know the whole Kyo
is beasts out twice he he would be stat
or would Hulk out as they called it at
the end of the second act and then he
would have a bigger Hulk Act and the
climax where he would solve the
situation and they really wanted us to
do the same thing well can we like to be
stout in episodes and could we have less
of the poetry reciting and all that and
you know we wanted more of the character
pieces in Atlanta and of course you're
in a constant struggle depending on your
ratings if you had the stronger your
ratings are the more you can do it the
way you want and the weaker your ratings
are the more help they will give you and
we we did pretty well the first season
and a half so by the second season we
were really doing the shows we wanted to
do and and was kind of disregarding the
the network pressures but they were
still there waiting and we were waiting
our time slot for the first season and
not we weren't it like a top ten show or
anything but we were winning the
timeslot which was very good and then I
think NBC we were on CBS NBC made a
change up and in in the lineup opposite
us and it had a couple sitcoms on
opposite us and they they replaced one
of them with a new sitcom called I think
it was full house and starring the Olsen
twins and this goddamn thing became a
hit
suddenly suddenly we were not winning
our time slot anymore
and the network was coming more and more
down on us of oh my god you're losing
your time slot and you know that's why
I've always hated the Olsen twins and
still do to this day
you've given me another reason to that's
right were there were there things that
you learned when you were writing you
know serial television that it would
inform your books later on yeah
certainly I mean one of the structure of
Song of Ice and Fire with his viewpoint
things and and cutting between the
viewpoints and all of them ending
essentially with I don't know
cliffhangers or interesting points is is
a structure I learned in television you
won't see it in my earlier novels but of
course working for network television
you have to have act breaks and
depending on the structure show is it a
4 4 at show is it before X plus the
teaser or five acts or said a teaser and
a tag you know what have you but you
always have to go out on an act break
before you go to the commercial and it
can be a cliffhanger that's a good act
break it doesn't have to be it can be
just a twist point or a new revelation
or a piece of information or you know
something is resolved but you know it's
it's for you watch the Law & Order it's
always to deter a moment you know we're
right before the commercial that uh oh
my god something has changed and the
idea is to bring you back after the
commercial of course but it's a good way
to end a chapter or an act and sometimes
it's pretty hard when you're designing
your story to come up with those act
breaks but you know that's why you get
the big books and it certainly works in
the books too I mean it's
keeps people reading you know they reach
the end of the chapter and and they want
to know what happens to that character
because they're in grossed and tirion
but gosh there's not another theory in
chapter for a while yet first I have to
read this are you a chapter or this Jon
Snow chapter before they finally get
back to Tyrion and those end by the time
they finish the argue chapter it isn't
kind of an
break there too and that hopefully draws
them back for the next one so yes and
also I think it helps your dialogue when
working in television and you're
actually hearing actors speaking your
lines you know I look at my earliest
scripts and and you know I would have
people giving long speeches you know
that take up a substantial chunk of the
page and it's you know it's too much you
get much better readability and and for
especially for contemporary audience if
the characters aren't giving speeches to
each other but are having much shorter
back and forth kind of kind of dialogue
and in